he's one of the most popular fighters
out there trying to take titles away
from Daniel Cormier good to see the man
who just took out Alexander Volkov in
UFC 229 and his chat with Joe Rogan
after his fight was something else good
to see you Derek Lewis how are you I'm
good thanks I think you know because
this is a radio and television broadcast
I think I should start this off by
letting the folks in the radio know that
your pants are on for this conversation
okay I just wanted to make sure what the
temperature was prior to the rest of
this conversation the air conditioning
up in here oh it doesn't matter I'm
sweaty right now okay just good enough
good enough that's good to know I
understand I understand I understand
that was mean that's just weak that was
you oh that was you voice on diff what
was your what was your phone like after
you get off out of the Octagon after
that in your home your postman shoe
laughter I have to change my number
business a lot of crazy people are
calling me out of the world wars family
members old friends I haven't talked to
you in a long time I'm always trying to
get my number one a hang guy we'll have
dinner and watch you know ideas one of
you I don't I don't get on texted people
just wanted to hang out and have lunches
or anything like that I'll be very
honest with you you'll get any kind of
endorsements from underwear companies
and stuff well I haven't professed
publicly the temperature of a certain
part of my anatomy maybe I should start
doing that I've got a big I've got like
truly one of the biggest audiences I
will ever have in my professional career
coming up on Sunday I'm calling the
Eagles Jaguars game on Sunday on the NFL
Network not a thrashing we're both team
to try it
what do you mean the trash they're not
the Texans or anything from Houston they
trash okay so you're a Texans fan it's
basically I'm just not the Saints though
I mean you're from nuts I know my family
members always give me hell about not
being
new on this fan but it is what it is
okay
so you're a Texans fan have you met
deshaun Watson have you I haven't met
any of them yet I mean what's going on
with the Texan so they sleep it on you
they start on Derek nothing I'm sleeping
on them because they they play too early
in the morning for me it's noon kickoff
Derek blue is here on the Rich Eisen
show okay so let's get into this with
you about how you got involved in
fighting how did you get involved in
fighting
oh my friend of mine slain car Carillo I
told me about this gym called silverback
he knew now you used to love to fight
all the time like in the streets and
stuff like that and he knew that uh that
would be a easy route for me to go and
make some money and help support my
family
okay so did you ever try boxing first
did you ever try so I was boxing for a
little bit with George Foreman probably
like three or four months what do you
mean so George the George Foreman yes
how did you get hooked up with him he
came to the gym I was training at and it
was looking for someone they're scouting
someone the fight his son and I Pro
fight number saw yes that's one of the
things that they do they like to look at
someone before they put him against his
son monk and I guess that's how he was
building this record up and trying to
see if they could find an easy target
from dumb beginning in the pro fight
with so what happened and so I went to
the gym spoiled one of these guys and I
beat him up pretty bad and they told me
no down I'm not the right guy to fight
his son so he just wanted to start
training me and managing me and stuff
like that and trying to get me to stop
boxing for him and I told him okay
that's fine let me see how my first MMA
fight goes and that really wasn't wanted
me to do MMA so they just wanted me to
stick
boxing sort of flew me out to Vegas and
start training out there for a little
bit with George Foreman um what is
manage okay with his manager yes but
George was what I mean you have
conversations with okay yes
Lisa go to gym and stuff like that okay
you sit sit down and watch me but um and
I told him no I don't think I'm boxing
is gonna be for me and at this time they
already gave me a call and it was about
to put me in our apartment across the
street from the gym I was training that
downtown Houston and um and I told her I
want to do boxing just stick to MMA
because I felt like MMA was more easier
than the boxing and so they took the car
away from me they took the car back yeah
it's a weap out your car yeah it was a
Buick anyway so what are you driving now
I Drive couple of cars Mercedes GTS okay
and waiting on my hard car to get
deliver next week so
okay so you've you've upgraded since the
since the Foreman ride little bit yeah I
still need to stay low-key okay
my wife she ran I like me being lavished
hmm why why are you doing the chicken
heads and come out the woodwork it's
true story
what what he what do you mean by that oh
you know like your little scallywags
come out with the little short dresses
and all that trying to come up to me
with the Ronda Rousey look-alike mass
and wig and everything trying to
highlight me so keep it low-key yeah on
the down-low okay and so you've been
successful in that so far woman thanks
so far so good I have to change my
numbers here and there but everything
has been good fantastic and so and and
so you have found UFC is more MMA is
more suitable for you why
it's more suitable summer basically a
street fighter and MMA it's mostly out
think is it was just like street
fighting without hitting in the nuts or
a gouge and stuff like that boxing I
believe you have to train a lot more
than you know
MMA so there's more in your arsenal in
the Octagon yeah even when I was BOTS
and I still wanted to kick somebody
pushed a lot though okay
cuz you know Andrew Golota kept hitting
Riddick Bowe down low at that one and
and it caused a whole brawl in Madison
Square Garden so you gotta be careful
about that but you're not gonna are you
ever gonna thinking of getting back in
the ring maybe no no Connor doing that
sure okay Derrick Lewis gonna take on
Daniel Cormier in UFC 230 what is
Cormier have in store do you think um I
think I may just gonna come out you know
I'm trying to wrestle me and try to get
me tired and trying to push the pace
really he really I know he's might not
say that I'm on his level but I think I
am but he thinking that I'm not really
well what do you think he's thinking
he's thinking that it's gonna be easy
fight for him you know thinking that I
don't train hard like he'd eat us and
just because he's limping wrestling and
thinking that he's gonna be an easy
fight for a lot of your colleagues Derek
and you're in the heavyweight division
don't think you deserve this fight have
you oh yeah I don't care of course they
would say that because just I guess
because my fighting style you know I'm
just everyone else's and mixed martial
artists I'm not a mixed martial artists
I'm a brawler and basically I guess
they're just thinking that I've been
running my fights pot luck but I just
think I've been winning more fights just
all on heart I don't know I saw that the
way you you hit Alexander Volkov I don't
know if did you think he thinks you were
lucky that the fighters just don't know
I'm glad I did not come up because in
the third round he's mocking my coaches
my coach he was saying all right Derek
now
man-ho call will say all right there
come on now now when you said you went
to your phone and you got a whole bunch
of messages after that Volkoff fight was
Putin one of them did you hear actually
Trump was one of them okay what he said
my guy he said you know you say it's a
great guy no the best guy and he's my
african-american friend right there and
that's what he called you on your okay
but you didn't butin staying away is
what you're sending he's staying away
mom sure you got a couple of spies okay
you know I mean here they call me UFC
2/3 so you are Houston guy your big
Rockets fan oh man yes okay big Rockets
fan I'd like to in the radio audience
will know what we're looking at the
Rondo cp3
set to that occurred in staples on
Saturday I'd love for you to break it
down as a fire as an MMA guy however you
wish and tell us what you think we're
gonna put it on the screen right over
here for Derrick Lewis it's taken on
Daniel Cormier and UFC - Thor what do
you think right here about this fight
and who gets the best of it right there
you get a cp3
finger point in the face and then and
then it's then throwing down what do you
think here Derek I think the team a sure
helped out to him you know I don't like
how James horn was so far back you know
he was look he's still not even in a
picture right now nah he's in the
picture I think James Harden should at
least jump in right here
well Brandon Ingram does right over the
top say you respect that out of Brandon
Ingram I guess if I was a Lakers fan I
would respect that but I still would
have liked them one of the Rockets
players and jumped into some well I mean
that that's just in terms of you know
teammate sort of I'm talking about
actual fist fisticuffs right here I mean
in terms of punches thrown who do you
think it's the best in here Rondo or
Rondo dude even though the referee got
in the way of the right hand around
Brockman you thought Rondo got the fight
as well but look Derek I think you'll
subscribe to this hit first hit hardest
right Rondo got him first and hardest
yeah but I like the uppercut that cp3
through though okay to go are you saying
that just because you're gonna be a
guest of the Rockets on Friday okay good
so you're gonna be there for for the
Rockets on Friday you're gonna be what
is an official captain or something like
that what do you know coming for the
roof they want me to be the ref because
they had they're eating one no part of
the punches thrown okay because Patrick
Beverley is coming to town no he's okay
so you're gonna be in there what size
are you just in case they wanted to have
some sort of you know put you in the
referee gear well mom 2x right now
yeah right now I'm 2 X user I'm a 3x but
I'm swimming down a little bit I'm 2 X
have you been doing the cardio that you
talk I don't know number cardio yeah
even the sex I know that um Cormier is a
wrestler so you know you gotta get them
hips down only okay so that's but
normally that you stay away from that
before a fight that's known of me using
some time a couplet I had sex the same
day just to see if it was okay in the
ring but you're a mythbuster is what
you're saying
yes Derrick Lewis I still have the
energy which they say they're taking
energy about sleeping okay so that's
part of your cardio regimen discount yes
coming into this camp yes okay and the
legs are so strong everything so strong
believe oxley enough
25 minutes okay and what does Cormier
need to look out for what do you say you
know I want a Derrick Lewis you have the
floor on what Daniel Cormier needs to
recognize I believe just need to watch
out for everything you know the fight is
never over with even in the last ten
seconds out of fight it's still not
always there I said I have a chance okay
very good
it's a pleasure to meet you a pleasure
to meet you your Instagram account is
off the charts pretty sure you've heard
that yes are you in charge of your
Instagram yourself there are no handlers
there are no Terra Klugh because the
dams are crazy
ain't no way no my handlers can handle
they're down well with the dams
I'm imagine all the sliding that's
happening there scallywags does your I
assume your wife has access to the
Instagram account of course not okay
he's changed his password as often it's
changes phone number American Hero
Derrick Lewis at the Beast underscore
UFC the one on episode you did this a
couple of years got thing with Ray Lewis
is still in the league and um I think
you saying what time is it
that's right I like that part what that
was was Ray joined ESPN for Sunday
morning for their Sunday morning show
and I'm you know I've known ray for
years and I just wanted to warn ray that
now that he's on my turf yeah I come out
of my smoke at 9:00 a.m. every Sunday
and I look trying the cameras at what
time is it you respect that game yeah so
game recognizing game in this okay all
day maybe you need to help me with my
Instagram game to know probably like
your job
are you telling me that's the end of
this interview at the Beast underscore
UFC on Twitter as well great to see you
sir
pleasure meeting you I've been become a
fan of yours and keep being you think
that Derek Lewis here on the Rich Eisen
show Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience